one of the things that I've been most
interested in lately is research on
something called mindset and mindset
science says that the way that you think
about something can actually transform
the effect that it has on you some of
the most fascinating findings include
how you think about aging can actually
impact how long you live and how well
you age people who have more positive
attitude toward aging live on average
eight years longer than people who have
a more negative attitude towards aging
and they actually thrive more and they
preserve all the things that we think
are good about youth and middle age they
actually do better as they get older and
some of this new research on mindset
says that the way that you think about
stress can actually help shape whether
it's effects are the toxic effects that
we fear like that stress can make a sick
or that stress can lead to burnout or
whether we experience actually much more
positive effects from stress things like
learning and growth and greater
engagement with life and with our
relationships if you're anxious and your
heart is pounding and you're sweating if
you're able to remember that okay well
this anxiety is distracting or
distressing but I also know that that
anxiety that heart pounding is my body
trying to give me energy that in some
way my body and brain are trying to rise
to the challenge literally just
remembering that five seconds when
you're experiencing anxiety can
transform that anxiety into a
physiological state that actually gives
you more energy that actually gives you
more confidence so one of the four moans
that the body releases during stress is
DHEA which is a precursor to
testosterone
it's literally strengthening it helps
the immune system and its effect on the
brain it's actually helped make the
brain more resilient to future stress it
increases neuroplasticity and this is
part of the normal stress response and
when you choose to view stress as an
opportunity to learn and grow your body
and brain actually responds releases
more of DHEA and actually puts you in a
biological state that makes it more
likely that you will learn and grow from
that stressful experience
you